next this is Duke hmm he's going to be  your brother Duke is a big shaggy  Newfoundland dog he's trying to figure  out where he fits in into the dynamic of  the family  sleep tight boys he needs to find a  happy place for himself he tries to  dominate max at first you can't help it  that the dog beds as small as it is  perfect this is comfy right I'm comfy  yeah I don't blame max for being upset  they go on an adventure in the streets  of New York City trying to get  along the way they get themselves into  all kinds of crazy antics get your  umbrellas out kitties because yeah they  come the Thunder  Duke and Max didn't know they would end  up best buddies come on you never know  where friends are gonna come from is it  home that way  seriously down